another season of southern charm season
six how are you feeling about season
believe it I'm feeling good I think it
is one of the best ones yet so it
provided some excitement in my life this
is the first season where we really get
to see you in mom mode full time what
was it like to balance that with filming
the show and continuing your social life
in this group yes and continuing being a
real estate agent which is a job of mine
that I have definitely had to scale back
on with having a baby
it is so untrue that you can have it all
as a mom you really can't you just have
to find balance you know see me trying
to do that it's very hard to have to
make a choice as to what is more
important to you they say something has
to give always yes what was the thing
that had to give for you for me it was
giving up a lot of my personal time my
alone time I lived a pretty cushy life
before I had Palmer not to say that I
still don't but I had a lot more me time
I was a much more selfish person
and when you have a kid you are forced
to be unselfish so that's me you learned
about yourself the ability to be
unselfish yes as a parent you are forced
to not put yourself first anymore it's
definitely a growing and learning
experience can't leave I'm gonna even
say this because it makes me nauseated
Kail like if something were to ever
happen to Palmer like hey darling honey
I know right now you become extremely
vulnerable as a parent you for the first
time in your life understand and know
unconditional love but at the same time
it can be debilitating because you worry
non-stop god forbid anything happened to
this child I will completely lose it so
it makes you very very vulnerable has
that changed how you operate within this
friend group are you more vulnerable now
I think you know being a mom and having
a child I've really learned what my
priorities are so I don't have
and I don't want to waste my time with
friendships or in situations that are
going to be you know detrimental to my
mental health southern charms cameran
Eubanks filling et in on all things mom
life with baby Palmer Wallach wins of
Mount Pleasant department store just
outside of Charleston South Carolina
it's parenting getting easier or harder
the older every stage with a baby is
something new something terrifying and
something exciting so I thought the
newborn stage was hard
no the toddler stage now is much harder
Palmer has started slapping me in the
face with her hands so like this morning
I asked her to give me a kiss and
instead of a kiss she took her little
hand and went Wow so yeah so we're
learning we're learning every day of the
school day with it every day yes every
day is the school day for sure along
with the Palmer talk at cam also let
this secret slip your husband is still
not on the show yeah you'll never be on
the show well oh there's a little
surprise coming because Jason makes a
cameo kind of up this season I wore him
down I wore him down Jason is a very
private very quiet person and I
convinced him to come to a group event
and I told him there will be a lot of
people you know it's not gonna be
focused on you so I think it calmed his
nerves and he actually shows up to
something so the viewers all get to see
my husband Wow at first at first yes
that's big
never say never he's a fan too like my
husband is a super fan of Bravo in
general and like southern charm like he
loves it that's a big misconception
people go oh he's just not supportive he
must hate the show no he loves it so I
think he was a little excited now that
it's become successful to be a part of
it okay
he's riding my coattails and my
coattails are about worn out so good
name
[Music]
[Applause]